okay he's not even sure what's going on
at 33
25 he says maybe it's a midlife crisis
for her
but he also mentions and i agree with
this um
cosmetically they can make her look much
younger
and i saw the photos that she posted on
instagram
she's 36 years old and she's getting
1 80 people to pay 25 dollars a month to
see her naked
so that's 47 000 a month um
whether it's through filters whether
maybe she's
she does have a lot of makeup and i'm
not putting her down at all she's been
able to parlay
her physical appearance with the
augmentation of either cosmetic surgery
or uh or cosmetics to look good enough
to have this
audience um but maybe he knows something
we don't know
i he probably does he's seen her coming
out of the shower
or he has seen her oh there's lots of
pictures on her instagram which will
unpack in a moment that are that are
blurred out at the right areas where you
can see her coming out of the shower and
breastfeeding one kid while doing the
other one's hair and the other one takes
a picture for
her right for her for the gram so you
know
we'll watch that train wreck in a minute
yeah i mean so
but to her credit look at the playboy
models
you know throughout the decades they are
airbrushed and they're made up perfectly
the hair
the skin you can always touch up yeah
yeah so and with today's technology it's
probably not that hard to do
um at 36.50 as a time stamp in rollo's
interview
uh you know he talks about her life
coach journey
started two or three years ago so she's
finding herself and now she's putting
herself in a position
i don't even know what the credentials
are to be honest about
being out there you have to have you
have to have blue blocking sunglasses
and that's about it okay but she was a
bartender before
and she made she was a seamstress for
kids clothes
and she was a teacher she was a
stay-at-home mom then
hit life coach so
i think what she's doing is parlaying
her fame
if you want to call it fame into trying
to tell other people
hey i discovered myself i'm not putting
her down
but this is how things are starting to
crystallize of
what's going on here one thing that the
husband mentioned
is that she has off the charts
interpersonal skills and that could be
true
she could be great interpersonally with
people and she appears that way
now she just has parlayed that into
um monetizing it for a monthly
subscription fee to show her body
i don't know everything that goes on in
her channel
in her fans only channel but she's
probably
completely naked uh but i don't know
what level of sexuality there is or
how if there's any censoring or what she
does but she's just walking around
in sexy lingerie or nude
there is a demand for that well we've
come to the realization today that
simps and their money are easily parted
with only fans
and it doesn't even have to be a hot 20
year old
a mommy of three in her 30s with some
decent airbrushing and a professional
photographer
you can land the job too
you